I think the question of acceptance of
lgbt folks really does depend on
geography in some places on earth.
Um,
I would say when it comes to legal
equality and cultural acceptance,
absolutely there's been this revolution
and progress has occurred at a pace that
even in our own lifetimes,
um,
was almost inconceivable in terms of how
quickly things have evolved.
At the same time,
just today,
two point 8 billion people living in
countries around the globe,
we're being gay as a crime.
Um,
and in some places like India,
progress toward equality has actually
been reversed.
So in back in 2013,
India Supreme Court re criminalized
sodomy and,
and same sex activity which had become
legal.
So there are examples of countries where
progress has actually been reversed when
we talk about how have things changed in
terms of equality or the movement toward
equality for Lgbt q folks?
I think the biggest and most dramatic
example is marriage equality,
which somewhat miraculously I think and
not inevitably did become the law of the
land.
And all 50 states,
thanks to the Supreme Court in the
obergefell decision decision are now
required to recognize same sex marriage,
but I think it's important to remember
that marriage equality does not mean or
is not synonymous with full equality in
terms of constitutional protections.
And in fact,
it,
it is in fact true that a couple could
get married on a Sunday and then one of
the partners goes to work on Monday,
puts a picture of his husband or her
wife on,
on the desk and gets fired because in
the majority of us states,
it is still completely legal for people
to be fired on the basis of sexual
orientation.
And the Civil Rights Act of 1964 doesn't
cover sexual orientation or gender
identity.
There's a movement,
uh,
among activists and,
and gay rights organizations to expand
the scope of the 1964 civil rights act
to go beyond race and gender and color
and national origin,
which are covered a categories.
But at this point,
sexual orientation is,
is not covered by the 1964,
uh,
legislation.
I guess the context,
it wasn't until 1973 that the American
psychiatric association came to the
conclusion that homosexuality in general
is not a mental illness,
and that was the year when the APA voted
to take homosexuality out of its
diagnostic manual.
Until that point,
every gay person,
no matter how well adjusted or healthy
or functioning was,
um,
considered mentally ill.
So that's the background.
And really that wasn't so long ago that
our most progressive doctors were,
were under the assumption or we're,
we're working on this theory that
homosexuality was in fact a mental
disease.
So I think conversion therapy is the
kind of the contemporary cousin to that,
to that belief that gay people are sick
and that they can be cured or that they
need to be cured.
Um,
and certainly,
you know,
dozens of medical,
uh,
established organizations ranging from
the Ama to youth organizations have
condemned conversion therapy.
But this idea that people who are gay
can be converted into not being gay is
indeed still alive.
And my sense is that at this point seven
states have outlawed conversion therapy
among miners.
Meaning that in the other 43 states,
it's still allowed for parents to send
their children,
their minor children.
I'm into this kind of therapy,
um,
and to,
to um,
acquire that kids under 18 go through
this process.
Um,
there haven't been studies of people
who've undergone the therapy and,
and you know,
consistently there's this sense of,
of a finding that the therapy not only
doesn't change people from being gay to
straight but inflicts its own harm and
trauma.
And there is federal legislation being
considered where there would be a
national ban.
Um,
which again,
I think is common sense and I hope that
as we see a new generation of young
people becoming more open and more
accepting,
um,
and,
and the sense of allies among teenagers
and young people,
I think that's the key to ultimately a
ending conversion therapy.